le département et antenne réunion vous
présente bien social
[Musique]
ils ont repris le chemin de l'école les
vacances sont terminées mais certains
enfants ont eu de belles aventures à
raconter comme paloma nayana ou encore
kanaka qui est la frontière bolivienne
ont fait une étonnante rencontre les
lamas s'échappe du musée c'est l'un des
ateliers proposés par le musée du sel
que nous avons suivis pendant les
vacances
[Musique]
lorsque la réunion rencontre la
cordillère des andes
il naît de cette union une créature
emblématique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est au musée du sel à saint leu que
lila maiana qui ricanent année leurs
camarades donne vie à leur nouvel ami
est en train de peindre un lama on a
commencé à le peindre en blanc l'a
laissé plein d'étapes taches blanches
quand on la repasse une deuxième couche
de marrons cela m'a été fait avec du
carton et
et du fer du métal mon ami du café et on
l'a prouvé mais là on a collé et on a
mis sur le lama aussi avant d'avoir ce
lama pour le mettre au musée on a vu une
baleine
elles étaient toutes amis mais du coup
on a dû remplacer avec al ahmar ils sont
refaire un petit peu comme font les fils
des bordures en plus nette
c'est olivier qui encadrent cet atelier
pour le photographe
le choix du lama s'est imposé en
référence à l'exposition du musée sur le
sel des andes
l'idée c'est de faire visiter la saline
donc d'ici de la pointe au sel hall
hamad qui vient de bolivie et d'ailleurs
comment il s'appelle la main un projet
qui permettent aux enfants de découvrir
la faune d'amérique latine fait l'ena m
ch dont les andes est deux fois sous le
bras et son site ou maman des fois il ya
un an si des lamas qui sont aux serbes
et aussi en montagne
[Musique]
pour olivier à l'origine d'un projet
similaire avec des zèbres la
collaboration avec les enfants est une
première j'ai rencontré la directrice du
musée
moi j'étais pas au courant qu'il y avait
des ateliers pendant les vacances pour
les enfants et donc elle a eu l'idée de
me proposer
organiser un atelier autour des du
papier mâché bac les enfants comment ça
se passe ses enfants ses nerfs lors
clair ça va chauffer ses contraintes ans
après il s'en remettre un peu partout
les parents je sais pas s'ils sont très
très content horaire ce centre malgré
ces petits dommages collatéraux les
peintres en herbe sont unanimes les
activités c'est très chouette parce
qu'on sa mise au mieux de s'ennuyer chez
nous devant la télé devant l'ordinateur
bon on peut enfin devenir faire quelque
chose on s'amuse vraiment c'était hyper
cool de se retrouver ici ensemble avec
tout le monde
bonchamp l'est pas
[Musique]
à la fin de la matinée le groupe part en
repérage à l'extérieur du musée
bonk aboli il en fait là il est dans le
musée il faut raconter une histoire
demain il faut imaginer le faire sortir
de deux dents et puis faire des photos
avec lui alors est ce qu'on le fait
sentir par ici où le fait sortir par
l'entrée qu'elle a bah moi je verrais
bien par l'entrée la barre l'occasion
d'inclure dans l'atelier une découverte
du site
et après on va le mettre devant les
salines là bas d'abord on va là où là ça
fait vraiment plaisir de voir nos
enfants s'épanouir sur des sites
départementaux et particulièrement ici
au musée du sel qui compte plein plein
de facettes
on a le côté historique avec le musée du
sel qui accueille toute l'année plus de
visiteurs et aussi il ya le côté
écologique puisque c'est l'environnement
même de ce musée est quelque chose de
riche et d'exceptionnel puisque il est
classé en espace naturel sensible et si
important cette transmission de notre
patrimoine c'est ce littoral qui est
magnifique et sur lequel les enfants
prennent du plaisir
[Musique]
le lendemain c'est le grand jour pour
boli a essayé de le matelas il découvre
enfin le paysage réunionnais qui
l'entourent a fallu faire un goûter du
siège aussi comment ramasse le seul à
avoir pour les enfants c'est l'occasion
de découvrir les bases de la
photographie les filles olivier lui y
voit un autre objectif la mise en oeuvre
l'objet qu'on a fabriqué en dans
l'espace s'approprier son fourneau
ventre vide et le mettre en mouvement
bon ok on va essayer de changer de place
un peu une fois familiarisé avec les
lieux boli s'installera durablement au
musée du sel où il recevra sûrement de
nombreuses visites de ses nouveaux amis
après vous le verrez vous à vous sauter
en l'air ok 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le musée du sel est le seul endroit où
l'on fabrique du sel à la réunion le
site a été fondé en 1942 par étienne du
sac
il est aujourd'hui gérée par le conseil
départemental le musée abrite
actuellement une exposition sur le sel
des andes
grâce à son atelier vacances les lamas
s'échappe du musée l'exposition possède
maintenant sa mascotte beau ni à l'ama
fabriqués par les enfants pour découvrir
le site et sa nouvelle mascotte vous
pouvez vous rendre à la pointe au sel à
saint leu ou contacter le musée au 02 62
34 67 00
[Musique]